when Nadia Savchenko went to meet
ukrainian President Petro poroshenko a
few hours after her release she looked
happiest when she was being reunited
with her comrades from the Nationalists
volunteer battalion I'd are after two
years in Russian captivity nadia
savchenko returned to ukraine as a hero
many in the country now hope she'll take
a leading role in politics no Sally I
can lecture her as a politician the
years that she spent in Russia have made
her a symbol of hope for Ukraine that's
why I think she's got what it takes to
be a politician sure does i live on a
multiple the political tactic which she
can't change anything by herself but as
part of a team she could as a leader
someone who can inspire people that
means a lot but I've seen Russian and
Ukrainian politicians make TV
appearances in my opinion it's all just
political PR the Moy boy at the epr one
television survey even claims
sixty-eight percent of callers said
they'd like Nadia Savchenko to become
president trabocchi VA la presidenta
Ukrainians if you want me to be
President ok I'll be President but I'm
still not convinced that our people have
learned not to sell their vote for a
sack of buckwheat Domo Yanis Kazushi ok
and frankly I can't say I wanted I want
to fly
but she does want to be involved in
politics as an opposition lawmaker in
the Ukrainian Parliament savchenko won a
seat while in Russian captivity when she
returned to Kiev last week she was
welcomed at the airport by her party
leader former Prime Minister Yulia
Tymoshenko while the government fails to
crackdown on corruption Timoshenko has
surged in opinion polls bolstered by
promises to cut energy prices the
addition of nadia savchenko Ukraine's
new heroine could soon shake up the
country's political landscape